how many of you have had to fill out
some sort of web form where even asked
to read a distorted sequence of
characters like this how many of you
found it really really annoying ok
outstanding so I invented that
or I was one of the people who did it
that thing is called a CAPTCHA and the
reason is there's to make sure that you
the entity filling out the form are
actually a human and not some sort of
computer program that was written to
submit the form millions and millions of
times the reason it works is because
humans at least nonvisually impaired
humans have no trouble reading these
distorted squiggly characters whereas
computer programs simply can't do it as
well yet so for example in the case of
Ticketmaster the reason you have to type
these distorted characters is to prevent
scalpers from writing a program that can
buy millions of tickets two at a time
now CAPTCHAs are used all over the
internet and since they're used so often
a lot of times the precise sequence of
random characters that are shown to the
user is not so fortunate so this is an
example from the Yahoo registration page
the random characters that happen to be
shown to the user were w AI T which of
course spell a word but the best part is
the message that the Yahoo help desk got
about twenty minutes later
this person thought they needed way this
of course is not a bad as this poor
person who ok now capture project is
something that we did here at carnagie
mellon over ten years ago and it's been
used everywhere
let me not tell you about a project that
we did a few years later which is sort
of the next evolution of captchas just a
project that we call recaptcha which is
something that we started here at
carnagie mellon then we turned it into a
startup company and then about a year
and a half ago Google actually acquired
this company so let me tell you what
this project started ok so this project
started from the following realization
it turns out that approximately 200
million CAPTCHAs are typed every day by
people around the world ok when I first
heard this I was quite proud of myself I
thought look at the impact that my
research has had but then I started
feeling bad so here's the thing each
time you type a CAPTCHA essentially you
waste 10 seconds of your time and if you
multiply that by 200 million you get
that humanity as a whole is wasting
about 500,000 hours every day typing
these annoying CAPTCHAs so then I
started feeling bad
and then I started thinking well of
course we can't just get rid of CAPTCHAs
music is the security of the web sort of
depends on them but then I started
thinking is there any way we can use
this effort for something that is good
for Humanity so see here's the thing
while you're typing a CAPTCHA during
those 10 seconds your brain is doing
something amazing your brain is doing
something that computers cannot yet do
so can we get you to do useful work for
those 10 seconds another way of putting
it is there's some humongous problem
that we cannot yet get computers to
solve but that somehow we can split into
tiny 10 second chunks such that each
time somebody solves a CAPTCHA they
solve a little bit of this problem and
the answer to that is yes and this is
what we're doing now so what you may not
know is that nowadays while you're
typing a CAPTCHA not only are you
authenticating yourself as a human but
in addition you're actually helping us
to digitize books ok so let me explain
how this works so there's a lot of
projects out there trying to digitize
books Google has one the Internet
Archive has one Amazon now with the
Kindle Store in the digitized books
basically the way this works is you
start with an old book like a physical
thing you've seen those things right
like I like
so you start with a book and then you
scan it now scanning a book is like
taking a digital photograph of every
page of the book it gives you an image
for every page of the book this is an
image with text for every page of the
book the next step in the process is
that the computer needs to be able to
decipher all of the words in this image
that's done using a technology called
OCR for optical character recognition
which takes a picture of text and tries
to figure out what the text is in there
now the problem is that OCR is not
perfect especially for older books where
the ink has faded and the pages have
turned yellow OCR cannot recognize a lot
of the words for example the things that
were in more than 50 years ago the
computer cannot recognize about 30
percent of the words so what we're doing
now is we're taking all of the words
that the computer cannot recognize and
we're getting people to read them for us
while they're typing a CAPTCHA on the
Internet
okay so next time you type a CAPTCHA
these words that you're typing are
actually words that are coming from
books that are being digitized that the
computer could not recognize I know the
reason we have two words nowadays
instead of one is because you see one of
the words is a word that we that the
system just got out of a book it didn't
know what it was and it's going to
present it to you but since it doesn't
know the answer for it it cannot grade
it for you so what we do is we give you
another word one for which the system
does know the answer okay we don't tell
you which ones which and we say please
type both and if you type the correct
word for the one for which the system
already knows the answer it assumes
you're human and it also gets some
confidence that you typed the other word
correctly and if we repeat this process
to like ten different people and all of
them agree on what the new word is then
we get one more word digitized
accurately so this is how the system
works and basically since we released it
about three or four years ago a lot of
websites that started switching from the
old CAPTCHA where people wasted the time
to the new CAPTCHA where people are
helping to digitize books so for example
Ticketmaster so every time you buy
tickets on Ticketmaster you have to
digitize a book
Facebook every time you add a friend or
poke somebody you help to digitize a
book Twitter and about 350,000 other
sites are all using reCAPTCHA and in
fact the number of sites that are using
reCAPTCHA is so high that the number of
words that were digitizing per day is
really really large it's about 100
million a day which is the equivalent of
about two and a half million books a
year and this is all being done one word
at a time by just people typing CAPTCHAs
on the Internet
okay now of course since we're doing so
many words per day funny things can
happen and this is especially true
because see now we're giving people two
randomly chosen English words next to
each other basically things can happen
so for example we presented this word
it's the word Christians there's nothing
wrong with it but if you present it
along with another randomly chosen word
bad things can happen
but it's even worse because the
particular website where we show this
actually happen to be called the Embassy
of the kingdom of God
yeah here's another really bad one uh
John Edwards calm
so we keep on insulting people left and
right every day now of course we're not
just insulting people see here's the
thing since we're presenting two
randomly chosen words just interesting
things can happen so this has actually
has given rise to a really big internet
meme that tens of thousands of people
have participated in which is called
CAPTCHA art I'm sure some of you have
heard about it here's here's how it
works okay imagine your is in your using
the Internet and you see a CAPTCHA that
you think is somewhat peculiar like this
CAPTCHA then what you're supposed to do
is you take a screenshot of it then of
course you fill out the CAPTCHA because
you help us digitize a book but then
first you take a screenshot and then you
draw something that is related to it
that's how it works
there are tens of thousands of these
some of them are very cute some of them
are funnier
and some of them like paleontological
shvisle they contain Snoop Dogg okay so
this is my favorite number of reCAPTCHA
so this is the favorite thing that I
like about this whole project this is
the number of distinct people that have
helped us digitize at least one word out
of a book the reCAPTCHA 750 million
which is a little over 10% of the
world's population has helped us
digitize human knowledge and it is words
it is numbers like these that motivate
my research agenda so the question that
motivates my research is the following
if you look at humanity's large scale
achievements these really big things
that humanity has gotten together and
done like historically like for example
building the pyramids of Egypt or the
Panama Canal or putting a man on the
moon there's a curious fact about them
and it is that they were all done with
about the same number of people it's
weird
they're all done with about a hundred
thousand people and the reason for that
is because before the internet
coordinating more than 100,000 people
let alone paying them was essentially
impossible but see now with the internet
I've just shown you a project where
we've gotten 750 million people to help
us digitize human knowledge so the
question that motivates my research is
if we can put a man on the moon with 100
thousand what can we do with 100 million
so based on this question we've had a
lot of different projects that we've
been working on let me tell you about
one that I'm most excited about this is
something we've been sort of semi
quietly working on for the last year and
a half or so it hasn't yet been launched
its called duolingo since it hasn't been
launched
I can trust you loo that okay so this is
a project here's how it started it
started with me posing a question to my
graduate student Severin hacker ok
that's Severin hacker so I posed a
question to my graduate student by the
way his that you did hear me correctly
his last name is hacker so I post this
question to him how can we get a hundred
million people translating the web into
every major language for free okay so
there's a lot of things to say about
this question first of all translating
the web so right now the web is
partitioned into multiple languages a
large fraction of it is in English if
you don't know any English you can
access it but there's large fractions in
other different languages and if you
don't know those languages you can
access it so I would like to translate
all of the web or at least most of the
web into every major language okay so
that's that's what I would like to do
now some of you may say well why can't
we use computers to translate so why
can't we use machine translation machine
translation nowadays is starting to
translate some sentences here and there
why can't we use it to translate the
whole web well the problem that is that
it's not yet good enough and it probably
won't be for the next 15 to 20 years it
makes a lot of mistakes even when it
doesn't make a mistake since it makes so
many mistakes you don't know whether to
trust it or not so let me show you an
example of something that was translated
with a machine it's actually was a forum
post with somebody who's trying to ask a
question about JavaScript it was
translated from Japanese into English so
I'll just let you read this person
starts apologizing from the fact that
it's translated with a computer ok so
the next sentence is going to be the
preamble to the question so he's just
explaining something I remember it's a
question about JavaScript
okay then
then comes the first part of the
question
then comes my favorite part of the
question
and then comes the ending which is my
favorite part of the whole thing
okay so computer translation not yet
good enough okay so back to the question
so we need people to translate the whole
web ok so now the next question you may
have is well why can't we just pay
people to do this we could pay
professional language translators to
translate the whole web we could do that
unfortunately it would be extremely
expensive for example translating a tiny
tiny fraction of the whole web Wikipedia
into one other language Spanish it you
know Wikipedia exists in Spanish but
it's very small compared to the size of
English is about 20% is the size of
English if we wanted to translate the
other 80% into Spanish it would cost at
least fifty million dollars and this is
even at the most exploitive outsourcing
country out there it would be very
expensive so what we want to do is we
want to get a hundred million people
translating the web into every major
language for free okay now if this is
what you want to do you pretty quickly
realize you're gonna run into two pretty
big hurdles two big obstacles okay the
first one is a lack of bilinguals okay
so I don't even know if there exists a
hundred million people out there using
the web who are bilingual enough to help
us translate okay that's a big problem
the other problem that you're going to
run into is a lack of motivation how are
we going to motivate people to actually
translate the web for free
this is normally you have to pay people
to do this so how are we going to
motivate them to do it for free now when
we were starting to think about this we
were blocked by these two things but
then we realized there's actually a way
to solve both of these problems with the
same solution there's a way to kill two
birds with one stone and that is to
transform language translation into
something that millions of people want
to do and that also helps with the
problem of lack of bilinguals and that
is language education okay so it turns
out that today there are over 1.2
billion people learning a foreign
language people really really want to
learn a foreign language and it's not
just because they're being forced to do
so in school for example in the United
States alone they're over 5 million
people who have paid over five hundred
dollars for software to learn a new
language ok so people really really want
to learn a new language so what we've
been working on for the last year and a
half is a new website it's called
duolingo where the basic idea is people
learn a new language for free while
simultaneously translating the web
and so basically they're learning by
doing ok so the way this works is
whenever you're just a beginner we give
you very very simple sentences there
of course a lot of very simple sentences
on the web we give you very very simple
sentences along with what each word
means okay and as you translate them and
as you see how other people translate
them you start learning the language and
as you as you get more and more advanced
we give you more and more complex
sentences to translate but at all times
you're learning by doing
okay now the crazy thing about this
method method is that it actually really
works okay first of all people are
really really learning a language we're
mostly done building it and now we're
testing it people really can learn a
language with it and and they learn it
about as well as the leading language
learning software so people really do
learn a language and not only do they
learn it as well but actually it's way
more interesting because you see with
duolingo people are actually learning
with real content as opposed to learning
with made up sentences people are
learning with real content which is
inherently interesting ok the other
thing so people really do learn language
but perhaps more surprisingly the
translations that we get from people
using the site even though they're just
beginners the translations that we get
are as accurate as those of professional
language translators which is very
surprising so let me show you one
example this is sentence that was
translated from German into English the
top is the German the middle is an
English translation that was done by
somebody who was a professional language
translator who we paid 20 cents a word
for this translation and the bottom is a
translation by users of duolingo none of
whom knew any German before they started
using the site if you can see it's
pretty much perfect now of course we
play a trick here to make the
translations as good as professional
language translators we combine the
translations of multiple beginners to
get the quality of a single professional
translator ok now even though we're
combining the translations the the site
actually can translate pretty fast so
let me show you this is our estimate of
how fast we could translate Wikipedia
from English into Spanish remember this
is 50 million dollars worth of value ok
so if we wanted to translate Wikipedia
into Spanish we could do it in five
weeks with 100,000 active users and we
could do it in about 80 hours with a
million active users since all the
projects that my group has worked on so
far have gotten millions of users we're
hopeful that we'll be able to translate
extremely fast with this project now the
thing that I'm most excited about with
duolingo is that I think this provides a
fair business model for language
education so here's the thing the
current business model for language
education is a student pace in
particular the student pays rosetta
stone
five hundred dollars that's
that's the current business model the
problem with this business model is that
95% of the world's population doesn't
have $500 so it's extremely unfair
towards the poor ok this is totally
biased towards the rich now let's see in
duolingo because while you learn you're
actually creating value you are
translating stuff which for example we
could charge somebody for translations
so this is how we could monetize this
since people are creating value while
they're learning they don't have to pay
with their money they pay with their
time but the magical thing here is that
they're paying with their time but that
is time that would have had to been
spent anyways learning the language ok
so the nice thing about duolingo is I
think it provides a fair business model
one that doesn't discriminate against
poor people so here's the site
here's the site we haven't yet launched
but if you go there you can sign up to
be part of our private beta which are
probably going to start in about three
or four weeks we haven't yet launched is
duolingo by the way I'm the one talking
here but actually duolingo is the work
of a really awesome team some of whom
are here so thank